[Music]
if it seems like politicians spend more
time these days talking about aunt
jemima getting taken off pancake mix and
who can use what bathroom than they
spend on voter suppression and raising
the minimum wage
it's only because you are absolutely
correct
in the last year there's been one
discussion in congress on weight raising
the minimum wage and
it only lasted two hours and seven
minutes meanwhile
there have been 14 hours of
congressional testimony on
cancel culture which doesn't include the
time this idiot spent reading a
children's book
i do not like green eggs and ham i do
not like them
sam i am but to be fair kevin mccarthy
is only the second most powerful man in
congress
now if you're wondering how we got here
maybe i can help in a segment called
how did we get here
when politicians get riled up about
something seemingly small like
dr seuss's family pulling his racist
books from shelves there's a name for it
it's called
the culture wars a culture war is a
conflict between groups struggling for
dominance of their values
beliefs and practices basically when a
politician can't win by making a logical
political argument
they resort to a culture war like
instead of coming up with a good
immigration policy they just yell about
how immigrants are going to steal your
jobs or
instead of finding a bipartisan solution
to climate change
they tell you joe biden is going to
steal your hamburgers
now that's a real example republican
congresswoman
lauren bobert tweeted it followed by why
doesn't joe stay out of my kitchen
and frankly he should because her
kitchen is full of guns
she said why doesn't joe stay out of my
kitchen and she's right
he needs to stay out of my kitchen until
he learns how to work a hot comb
if you're not old and you're not
black then don't you try to understand
that joke
here's another example this is rachel
levine
she waited over a month to be confirmed
as assistant secretary of health
of course there was no rush we're only
in a global pandemic
a lot of republicans opposed levine's
nomination because um let's check her
qualifications oh
she's a pediatrician she graduated from
harvard she served as pennsylvania's
secretary of health
so she's literally done the job before
let's see
if she was confirmed it would make her
the first openly transgender
federal official in history i found it
i found the reason it's because they're
terrible
so terrible that kentucky senator rand
paul just
kept repeating the words genital
mutilation over and over again during
levine's confirmation hearing
genital mutilation has been nearly
universally condemned
genital mutilation has been condemned by
the who
the united nations children's fund the
united nations population fund
according to the who genital mutilation
is recognized
internationally as a violation of human
rights
genital mutilation is considered
particularly egregious
because as the w.h.o notes it is nearly
always carried out on miners
that man is not just terrible he's
raisins in the potato salad
terrible and if that clip didn't make
any sense
that's the entire purpose of a culture
war it's not supposed to make any sense
it's supposed to scare people away from
wanting change
it's one of the oldest tricks in the
book not green eggs and ham
i'm talking about the book that
convinces people that anti-racists are
going to turn the tables and
enslave white people or that saying
black lives matter means you're anti-cop
or that gay people are going to steal
your children and raise them
though frankly you should be so lucky
and if you think a war on culture is
some kind of exaggerated metaphor
it's not the ideas that conservatives
sling around in the culture wars are
dangerous
and they cost people's lives it's not a
coincidence
that the fir that the worst year for
violence against transgender and gender
non-conforming people
was 2020 when the trump administration
reversed laws that protected transgender
americans and
it's not a coincidence that anti-asian
hate crimes rose 150
last year after the president publicly
demonized asian people
now this is the part of the segment
where we usually reach back and find an
obscure example from history but
not today today we only have to reach
back to 2020 when old
rand genital mutilation paul blocked a
bill that would make lynching
a federal crime no one could understand
why rand paul wouldn't want to pass a
law called
the emmett till anti-lynching act but
paul didn't have to explain himself
because he waited until everyone was
distracted
on the day of george floyd's funeral who
blocks an
anti-lynching bill during a funeral that
is some
next level evil joffrey baranthian heard
that and was like
too far okay so here's the obscure part
in 1918 congressman leonidas dyer
also introduced a bill to make lynchings
a federal crime but
it was defeated because and this was the
literal reason
they wrote down on paper they needed a
tool to stop black men from
raping white women can you imagine
putting something that awful in writing
i won't even put gossip in a text
i put it in a voice memo during the next
year
in the red summer of 1919 lynchings
exploded then in the 1920s the naacp
begged congress to pass an anti-lynching
bill they even financed a study that
proved
that black men weren't going around
attacking cairns
black men were just doing what black men
in the 1920s did
minding their own dang business and
making finger waves look
good but the bill failed and so has
every
anti-lynching bill from the 1920s until
now
to this day there has never been a law
against
lynching in the united states this law
is more overdue than a woman who is
15 months pregnant and even she would be
like
forget me just pass the bill now you
might be wondering if there could be a
reason for this besides racism
well let me ask you this do you think
there has never been a transgender
person
qualified to work in government in the
history of this country
do you think it's a coincidence that
congress is 77 percent
white and that set that it's also 73
percent male
or that 83 percent of the federal
judiciary is white
this isn't racism it's beyond racism
this is white supremacy because the
purpose of a culture war is to make sure
people are afraid of change and
resisting change
means maintaining power and that's why
they're fighting to keep racist
children's books and confederate statues
and
that's why they'd rather talk about
cancel culture than domestic terrorism
because culture wars and white supremacy
go together like
well green eggs and ham and i do not
like them
sam i am this has been how do we get
[Music]
here
[Music]
you